often when we're sick typically what we
want to do is just
curl up in bed and go to sleep and in
part
what we're trying to do is sleep
ourselves well
because there's a very intimate
association
between our sleep health and our immune
health
[Music]
we know that individuals reporting less
than seven hours of sleep a night
are almost three times more likely to
become infected
by the rhinovirus otherwise known as the
common cold
we also know that women sleeping five
hours or less
a night are almost 70 percent more
likely to develop pneumonia
but we've also discovered that sleep can
play a role
in your successful immunization so
in one study they took a group of
individuals and they
limited them to four hours of sleep a
night
for six nights and in the other group
they gave them a
full night of sleep each and every one
of those nights
and then during that time period they
gave them a flu shot
and they measured the response to that
flu shot
what they discovered is that in those
individuals
who were sleeping just four hours a
night they went on to produce
less than 50 percent of the normal
antibody response
so in other words if you're not getting
sufficient sleep
in the week or the days before you get
your flu shot
it may render that vaccination far less
effective
as a consequence what this tells us and
now what we're starting to learn
is that it's during sleep at night
including deep non-rem sleep
when we actually restock the weaponry
within our immune arsenal we actually
stimulate the production
of numerous different immune factors and
furthermore
the body actually increases its
sensitivity
to those immune factors so you wake up
the next day
as a more robust immune individual
so when it comes to your immune system
you should perhaps think of sleep as one
of the best
health insurance policies that you could
ever wish for